ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt meine lieben freunde und wir
befinden uns immer noch in unserer
kleinen höhlen base hier vorne in der
liga wo kommen diese ganzen geräusche
her ist das irgendwie aus dem zimmer
[Musik]
denn viele sind da denn es ist ja klar
dass das der letzten folge so unfassbar
laut beziehungsweise auch jetzt mal die
ganze zeit wir haben hier ein loch na
gut das müssen wir auf jeden fall
erstmal dann bewegen wir uns jetzt
wieder aus unserer sicheren base raus
rüber indega das ist wirklich einfach
eine zombie höhle hier sind so viele von
den sack
[Musik]
doch ein zombie village es ist völlig in
ordnung dass sie allein kommt alles easy
wien haben wir bewegen uns allerdings
sind diese richtung hier vorne denn hier
links waren wir schon fast überall wir
gehen jetzt allerdings mal nach rechts
rüber nehmen erst mal noch kurz das
eisen mit ich würde sagen ich
konzentriere mich jetzt gar nicht mal so
riesig auf die kohle sondern erst mal so
ein bisschen aufs ausleuchten ich weiß
hier kommt schon wieder eine spinne
angelaufen
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr von
wowi kamen allerdings befindet sich hier
wir müssen auf jeden fall hier vorne
lang hier waren wir noch nicht wir haben
hier ganz viele fledermäuse ich weiß
nicht was ihr 26
[Musik]
ich hänge im netz ich hänge jetzt das
kannst du doch wieder nicht ausdenken
was hier abgeht mit den ganzen monstern
er versteckt sich dahinter hinter den
steinen der store ist der kripo jetzt
schild noch da hinten wir konzentrieren
uns erstmal auf den zombie dahinten ich
weiß nicht ob ich überhaupt genügend
pfeiler habe um es mit den allen jahr
aufzunehmen den krieg nach vorne kriege
ich auf jeden fall auch noch
und jetzt werde ich als allererstes erst
mal dieses wasser hier die ganzen wir
sind den riesigen höhle
ich weiß nicht ob ich mich da gerade
verguckt habe aber wir sind in einer
riesigen schlucht da kommt schon wieder
ein skelett um die ecke gelaufen
das kannst du doch wirklich nicht
ausdenken was hier abgeht in der letzten
episode war es ja auch schon so heftig
was mit den monstern hier los war aber
in dieser folge was sich allein in den
ersten minuten hier schon wieder alles
erleben muss
das grenzt wirklich an
ich werde mich erst mal aufs komplette
aus leuchtenden konzentrieren da unten
haben wir auch schon wieder ein zombie
stehen hier unten geht es wirklich
völlig ab die ganzen fledermäuse fliegen
hier um die haben wir noch gold das
nämlich gleich alles mit wir müssen uns
so aber das ist okay die kohle hier oben
nämlich auch noch mal eben mit ihr fragt
euch wahrscheinlich luca warum nimmst du
so viel kohle mit du hast noch genug
kohle zum brennen und so das sollte doch
alles ausreichend ja die sache ist
allerdings dass wir später irgendwann
unsere ganze kohle tauschen können
bei sonne wieder da und er könnte uns
dann eventuell dafür smaragde geben und
fürs maracle können wir uns dann
vielleicht falls wir wirklich keine
diamanten finden sollten einfach
diamanten herr trading egal wie hoch es
geht denn jetzt jahr
[Musik]
hier oben brauchen wir allerdings auf
jeden fall nicht mehr hingehen von daher
baut das jetzt einfach mal so ein
bisschen zu komme ich denn jetzt hier
runter
ich werde mich einfach so ein bisschen
hier so im lg mäßig fortbewegten
[Musik]
schlucht in der schlucht und leute 2 max
hier
ich habe keine ahnung was das gerade war
ob sie irgendwo im krieg der guard jetzt
werde ich auch noch geschossen
ich werde mich jetzt mal ganz easy peasy
drum herum bewegen und nur ganz kurz
gucken wir hier irgendwo diamanten haben
die restlichen ärzte sollen wir jetzt
auf jeden fall erstmal egal sein hier
ist allerdings nichts am start immer
ganz kurzen eisen und kohle mit halbem
herzen fragt bekommen wollt bei mir
geklingelt paketdienst ich bin durch
kurz teilnetz von der von dem spiel menü
[Musik]
da bin ich wieder meine lieben freunde
wir befinden uns immer noch in der höhle
ich hoffe ihr habt die lava tablets
genossen hier vorne geht gar nichts ab
wir brauchen noch immer noch die haben
wir leute schreiben ist hier das kannst
du doch nicht auslegen wie viele creeper
hier überall schön hier nehmen hier ganz
kurz mal eben noch dass leute die hier
leute hier
wie sollen wir es denn überhaupt
hinkriegen frage ich mich gerade diese
komplette höhle hier heute 2 max hier
[Musik]
leute 2 max hirt und läutet bei nexteer
wollen leute schreibe ich hier
[Musik]
noch hat
klar
[Musik]
der kleine eisenstadt land
wie sollen wir es hinkriegen als wir
sind jetzt auf jeden fall am ende
angelangt aber die soll man hinkriegen
die komplette höhle hier vernünftig
auszuleuchten so dass keine zombies oder
kripo oder skelette mehr an staat kommen
die kommen ja von überall ich würde
sagen wir konzentrieren uns erstmal
darauf hier vorne wieder das wasser
zuzumachen so dass hier auf jeden fall
nicht mehr irgendwelche nassen flächen
sind hier unten haben wir noch ein
bisschen blut rumliegen pfeile sind auf
jeden fall immer wichtig da ich ja viel
mit pfeil und bogen hier arbeite das
gold hier vorne nämlich noch mal eben
mit
und jetzt konzentrieren wir uns würde
ich sagen erst mal wieder auf die bühne
denn diese höhle beziehungsweise
schlucht hier vorne
das ist wirklich extrem an unserer welt
sind wir auf jeden fall die mittlerweile
schon wieder einmal warum wächst ja ich
weiss nicht mehr aber ich habe auch
keine feinde dabei ich habe keine feier
dabei ich weiß nicht mehr in welche
richtung wir gegangen sind hiervon oh
mein gott wir sind auf jeden fall noch
die meisten meiner sachen die sammel
nicht mal eben schnell auf und kommt
später der nächste kritiker
das ist jetzt komplett egal alter jetzt
muss ich das komplette mlg player aus
hassel neben schnell wieder zurücklaufen
unser base here for nicht wieder von
irgendwo abgeschossen
ganz schnell auch die tür zumachen auch
immer wichtig und zumindest erstmal
viele sachen hier vorne reinpacken und
sichern so dass ich den rest auch mit
kriegen kann welche nicht gerade ja
erstmal zu hause war
da musste ich wieder hierhin laufen die
ganzen sachen holen hätte wieso sterben
die eigentlich mit meissen schwert
genauso schnell die vorhin mit meinem
diamant schwert alter
[Musik]
denn das kannst du ja nicht ausdenken
ihr unten alles in der hölle mann ich
komme richtig
[Musik]
microsoft bringt mich echt an meine
grenzen was meine leute frei
[Musik]
läutet freaks hier
fasse ich einfach nur noch durch ich
hatte hier einfach nur noch durch
mir ist alles egal ich will einfach nur
meine items haben
[Musik]
ich habe den krieg nicht gehört als
sechstes ich möchte jetzt erstmal alles
aus ich konzentriere mich auf gar nichts
wir merken ich bin im krieg ich bin im
krieg leute
und lenker im krieg kann niemand
aufhalten
[Musik]
es ist alles ausgleicht neckar mehr
kannst du hier nicht ausleuchten
wo kommen dann trotzdem die ganze zeit
noch diese monster her dass kleine alles
klar du kannst du das wirklich nicht
ausdenken ich bedeutet wächst hier und
leute 2 max hier
das ist nicht mehr normal was mach
einfach klar geht es hier unten auch
noch lang
[Musik]
und leute zwei bis vier leute 2 bis 4
und der schweiz 4
das beschreibt 11 diese höhle das
beschreibt wirklich 11 mein glück ich
bereite mich jetzt mal ganz kurz herein
und brat man auch ein bisschen reisen
und rüste mich jetzt auch noch mal
vernünftig ausmachen ein paar läufer
warten das kannst du dir doch wirklich
nicht ausdenken wie viele creeper und
skelette in dieser höhle sind ich merke
dass mein heftig verzauberter bogen weg
ist der wird wahrscheinlich von dem
krieg in die luft gesprengt allerdings
würde ich sagen wir sind im krieg
wir sind noch immer die leute zwar
wächst hier
[Musik]
ich werde ganz schnell sind einfach ok
perfekt nach vorne ist der krieg hier
[Musik]
da denkst du wirklich du hast alles
ausgeleuchtet was alles danke fürs
reisen jungs jedoch ein zombie ich weiß
nicht was hier von ab jedoch leute
freiwillig hier irgendwo ins bonner ist
oder so aber das ist doch nicht mehr
normal oder
schreibt mir mal bitte in die kommentare
ob er da schon mal irgendwo erlebt habt
entweder selber in minecraft welt oder
bei irgend einem youtuber dass da so
viele kripo am start sind und dann auch
immer nicht nur einer sondern halt mal
drei oder vier auf einmal oder so und
guckt aber von wo sollen sie denn kommt
denkst du die spawnen hier oben und
dürfen dann die ganzen weg runter lassen
und dann geht es jetzt mal ab hier vorne
wieder in die andere richtung hier vorne
waren wir schon fast überall deswegen
brauche ich da jetzt auch mal ganz
schnell so ein blog hin
hier war allerdings erst mal noch ein
bisschen reisen was wir mitnehmen
konnten
und ich weiß auch sonst wirklich nicht
in welche richtung wir hier noch gehen
wollen es kommt mir so vor
jetzt hätten wir alles hier irgendwie
schon entdeckt hier war mir auf jeden
fall schon überall
hier waren wir noch gar nicht nach vorne
das skelett hat sich direkt mal
verabschiedet ich glaube da hinten ist
die oma da hinten ist die große schlucht
in der wir schon waren und daher werde
ich mich jetzt erst mal ganz kurz aus
ausleuchten konzentrieren
hier muss noch mal irgendwann muss hier
[Musik]
irgend jemand der hier gerade zukunft
eventuell mal eine compilation hochladen
mit allen creeper begegnungen in dem
projekt minecraft mit luca ich glaube
das youtube video wird drei stunden
gehen
wir gehen auf jeden fall in dieser
höhlen episode schon mal deutlich besser
vor als auch in den letzten episoden
auch generell mit dem ganzen fackeln
setzt und so dass man immer genau weiß
wo man wieder hin muss das macht schon
sind die kohle lasse ich jetzt einfach
mal da
denn ich möchte mich jetzt auf jeden
fall noch ein bisschen an sekunden hier
machen hier vorne das brauche ich jetzt
einfach mal ein bisschen zu weit ihr
kennt ja meine ansicht ich finde auch
dass höhlen immer so ein bisschen schön
aussehen sollten sofern sie es denn
können hier vorne den gang machen wir
auch zu da gibt jeder häusern ab wir
sitzen jetzt ja allerdings dass das hier
vorne alles zugebaut werden kann von
daher kann ich auch dass hier komplett
zu machen hier unten die ärzte haben wir
geholt ich still bisschen von daher
können wir allerdings diesen gang hier
komplett zu bauen da wir da ja jetzt
schon waren und daher gehen wir jetzt
erstmal weiter hier lang
selbstverständlich treffen wir vorne
wieder auf dem skelett es müssen doch
auch das motto des mobs potter
[Musik]
denn das sind reaper mops potter ist
dann geht das alles erklären dann wird
das alles erklären
oh mein gott es ist ein skelett jobs vor
woher kommen dann die ganzen krieg ich
würde sagen wir schauen uns jetzt noch
mal kurz die truhe hier an wir haben
hier eine menge schwarzpulver drin ein
fehlerfall buch das können wir auf
unsere schuhe draufpacken melonen kerne
haben wir bereits und den rest auch und
hier haben wir namensschilder drin und
auch noch schwarzpulver verrottetes
fleisch fäden und auch keine ahnung was
das letzte noch war
allerdings werde ich die truhen hier mal
ganz kurzen mitnehmen und ich glaube ich
werde mich hier jetzt sogar mal hoch
bauen adresse kiste ich lasse nicht mein
schwein ist kaputt und den schild da
unten drin
und er ist auf jeden fall tot wären wir
vorne eine kiste hier gibt die höhle
sogar auch noch weiter ich weiß nicht
wie es sein kann dass wir immer solche
riesigen hüllen finden allerdings ist
der gang gar nicht mal so lange vorne
geht aber auch noch weiter das kannst du
nicht aus denke ich geht sogar weiter
wieder in der mine alter ist das heftig
allerdings haben wir ja oh mein gott
die aktiven philipp zombie wir haben ja
hier vorne den sport entdeckt bzw
ein stockwerk tiefer und hier ist die
kiste drin hier drunter ist sogar auch
noch ein zombie die galizier darunter
auch noch weiter das kannst du nicht
ausdenken wir haben auf jeden fall in
der kiste cola
wir haben reisende haben sensor schienen
die brauchen wir nicht goldenen apfel
nämlich auf jeden fall mit so die
wichtigsten sachen habe ich jetzt mal
mitgenommen also rcz wie können von da
hinten immer noch zombies com alter ich
verstehe es nicht
ich weiß allerdings gerade auch ehrlich
gesagt nicht mehr wo wir den spanner
genau gefunden hatten ich glaube das war
genau dort hinten am ende also so weit
von unserer base entfernt war es dann
doch gar nicht die sache ist ich hab mir
jetzt 54 leitern gemacht und ich habe
auch eine menge bruchstein mitgenommen
das heißt ich werde das hier erst mal
ganz kurz ein bisschen zu bauen und mir
auch mit der kraft in benxi vorne eben
kurz eine bruchstein treppe machen
sodass zumindest wir nachher über gucken
können wenn wir wieder kommen sollten
und einfach wissen ob die monster sind
oder nicht hier unten werde ich jetzt
noch ein bisschen weiter nach unten
bauen damit wenn wir auf wasser stoßen
dass das auf jeden fall da unten rein
läuft
oder sind war das ging jetzt echt
relativ schnell
und wir sind sogar echt relativ nah an
unserer welt dran ich werde jetzt hier
vorne
ich weiß es das setzen nicht so schön
aussehen wird allerdings werde ich auf
jeden fall direkt neben unserer treppe
ich jetzt mal ganz kurz ohne cobblestone
wand hier hoch ziehen damit wir
zumindest wissen wo unser eingang ist
ich werde jetzt mal in jede richtung
eine fackel daran setzen dass wir das
auf jeden fall wissen und werden jetzt
wieder rein gehen wollen den wir hier
einfach runter bauen hier quasi den
cobblestone ab den ich hier
fälschlicherweise hingesetzt habe und
können jetzt können jetzt hier auf jeden
fall so entspannt runtergehen
das ist auf jeden fall meine lieben
freunde ich würde sagen ich dass sie
hier noch ganz schnell so ein bisschen
leitern hin damit auf jeden fall ein
bisschen besser klappt beziehungsweise
kann ich die sogar hier hinsetzen ja das
funktioniert auch
da kann ich unseren richtigen weg hier
runter bauen
[Musik]
haben sie das gesehen ich dachte ich
muss nichts aber dann doch nichts ich
dachte gerade ich wäre kein wasser mehr
drin da unten weil das ja eigentlich
aufgehört hatte aber irgendwie war dann
doch wasser auf jeden fall dachte ich
bevor ich sterbe nämlich auf jeden fall
dieses post mortem dingen die hand also
dieses totem der unsterblichkeit und
jetzt wissen wir auf jeden fall fürs
nächste mal dass wir hier vorne unseren
spanner am start haben jeder irgendwie
eine monster falle bauen können und wenn
wir aber nach hause wollen können wir
einfach die leiter hoch gehen und ab
hier vorne schwimmen wir dann einfach
hoch dann geht sogar ein bisschen
schneller als über die leitern dann kann
ich die das nächste mal auch noch
abbauen
dann kommen wir auf jeden fall hier oben
raus den blogger muss sich auf jeden
fall noch mal ganz kurz abbauen und dann
kommen wir entspannt hier vorne an und
können uns direkt nicht auf die spiele
konzentrieren hab ich gerade überhaupt
keine nerven sondern uns einfach nur
noch auf unser bettchen freund freunde
hier vorne die ducks hatten lieferbar
die rose an diese skelette grund
[Musik]
und leute träumen
ich werde meine items mal ganz kurz
wieder oh mein gott wie schönes dieser
bambus dahinten gewachsen
was ich sagen wollte war dass sich bei
ganz kurz weil items gar nicht mal da
rein packe sonder bzw
hier kann ich das hier ganz kurz hin
packen meine rüstung die ja fast
komplett beschädigt ist hier unten
die möchte ich mir auf jeden fall noch
aufbewahren bis ich wieder diamanten
finden sodass sich die dann reparieren
kann allerdings kann ich ja schon mal
anfangen meine sachen hier so ein
bisschen in die kisten trip
einzusortieren
zum beispiel hier vorne alles was macht
beim nächsten mal
das ist mir jetzt ein bisschen es ist
ein bisschen zu stressig macht die
reparatur beim nächsten mal ich bin auf
180 ich nehme schon wieder seit zwei
stunden auf meine lieben freunde wenn
euch diese höhlen episode teil 2 heute
gefallen hat es war action pur das gern
einen daumen hoch und ein video hier da
abonniert main kanal und klickt auf die
glocke als eine benachrichtigung
bekommen wollt sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen das nächste video geht
übermorgen online es wird eine echt
kurze folge denke ich dafür weil diese
die letzte und vorletzte folge alle
extrem lang waren ich hoffe ihr freut
euch dennoch wir werden das hier auf
jeden fall wieder aufbauen wir werden
was an der villa wieder verändern weil
wir ganz ganz viel von der glatten quad
blog haben also schaltet auf jeden fall
über morgen um 20 uhr wieder ein
wir sehen uns
[Musik]